bonjour à tous comment est ce que vous
allez aujourd'hui alors je viens tout
juste de terminer mon live tweet c'est
la raison pour laquelle je garde ce
secteur pour venir vous parler d'un truc
est super intéressant je sais pas si
vous avez passé cette info alors je
l'aimé déjà sur mon compte instagram
j'aime bien henry jamie sur tik tok et
je voulais vous le partager directement
aussi sur youtube il ya quelques jours
je vous parlais effectivement des
attaques d'apple
les attaques d'apple c'est ça en fait
les retailles d'apple c'est plutôt ça
c'est ce petit accessoire là qui est
super sympa et qui vous permet de venir
retrouver vos objets que vous avez perdu
vous avez égaré très facilement voulu
mettre sur des clips où il met dans un
sac pour le mettre dans votre
portefeuille dans tout ce que voulait
même sur un parapluie sur un vélo
donc ça c'est super intéressant et apple
utilise l ap le cas si l'application qui
s'appelle localisés pour venir retrouver
justement ces objets une info médias et
sorties qui est vraiment extrêmement
intéressante qui vous montrent
effectivement et bien que apple a oublié
de désactiver ou autre cas n'a pas fait
n'a pas de style en tout cas on peut y
avoir accès à une application pour
développeurs directement dans son
application localisé alors je vous
montre comment ça marche surtout qu'ils
vont vraiment vraiment vraiment
surprenant je suis surpris en fait si
vous voulez que connaissant la façon des
pointilleux d'apple qu'il n'est pas du
tout supprimer ça alors je voulais vous
le montrer très très très rapidement si
la raison pour laquelle effectivement
bien on reste sur le vif comme ça dans
ce dans ce set up alive twitch
d'ailleurs je vous invite à venir nous
rejoindre sur twitch pour tout savoir
effectivement du high tech tous les
jours on fait une revue presstek où je
vous dis tout je vous en parle et puis
on se retrouve de temps en temps le soir
lorsqu'a une très très belle sortie ou
un petit peu un petit peu à part pour
venir effectivement et bien voir ce
qu'il en vient à le regarder je vous
montre ça ça effectivement c'est votre
appli vous connaissez peut-être
l'application qui s'appelle localiser et
là vous êtes en train de localiser vos
clés alors b clés sont juste à côté dans
sa communication ici est en fait pour
avoir accès à ce mode développeur et
bien il faut appuyer cinq fois ici sur
clay maison 1 2 3 4 5
oi oi oi oi oi oi oi oi
ça c'est quand même un petit peu un
petit peu dingo de la part d'apple
d'abord accès à ça alors vous avez accès
à différentes petites informations et
vous le voyez ici alors je pense que ce
sont effectivement les informations pour
me retrouver votre clé on voit qu'on a
un écho mode ou pas un eco mode qu'on
peut activer ou désactiver directement
ici on voit qu'on peut venir permuter
ici pour tout vous dire je ne sais pas
réellement à quoi tout cela correspond
je crois comprendre effectivement qu'on
a des données de position peut-être en
tout cas ce qui est sûr est que je vous
conseille de ne pas venir trifouiller
tout ça on peut le voir c'est
intéressant c'est très intéressant de
voir effectivement que apple n'a pas
supprimé cette partie là il a laissé
intégré directement dans son application
je ne doute pas que sur une prochaine
mise à jour tout ça ça saute et qu'on ne
le retrouvera pas en tout cas ce que je
vous conseille de venir le désactiver la
même manière vous allez puis cinq fois
ici 1 2 3 4 mm 4 suffit voiliers et ça
disparaît on fait un petit tour de magie
donc si vous voulez faire un tour de
magie fait un deux trois quatre boum ça
apparaît un tour de magie 1 2 3 4
boum 2 3 4 boum ça disparaît voilà un
peu donc je voulais vous le montrez je
voulais vous en parlez surpris
effectivement que cette fonctionnalité
soit accessible directement depuis votre
iphone je suis aujourd'hui sur la
version de ios 14.5 peut-être qu'une
mise à jour vient supprimer ça peut-être
bien évidemment ça me paraîtrait avoir
un sens en tout cas dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez au banc commentaires
surprenants très surprenant alors bien
évidemment pour ça il faut que vous
alliez des airbags
il faut que vous puissiez effectivement
venir les rechercher voilà c'était une
petite info un petit peu courtes comme
ça une petite actu cela bouge pas des
caïds un phoque est sympa on arrive on
se la met et on la partage ensemble
voilà donc je dis moi vous ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire quant à
nous on retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler tech alors je vous ai
déjà parlé d attaque deux jours j'ai
fait une vidéo là dessus que je trouvais
intéressant parce qu'elle est plein de
points venir aborder effectivement sur
ces fameux airtag pour comprendre
effectivement ce qu'on peut faire pas
faire essayer ça et on en reparlera
empreinte est un peu plus poussée des
retailles mise en situation réelle tout
ça un peu plus tard mais évidemment sur
youtube d'ici là je vous embrasse donne
rendez vous très rapidement sur youtube
et puis dès lundi n'est évidemment 11h
sur le live tweet à bientôt
ciao